it uh the ukrainian president vladimir
lenski has tweeted this information uh
russian occupation forces are trying to
seize the chernobyl nuclear power plant
uh he says our defenders are giving
their lies so that the tragedy of 1986
will not
be repeated he says i have reported this
to the swedish prime minister this
is a declaration of war against the
whole of europe our international
affairs editor dominic waghorn was in
chernobyl he was reporting from there uh
not too long ago here on sky news a
matter of days ago and he pointed out
that chernobyl is significant because uh
it is the shortest direct route to the
ukrainian capital kiev
from the belarus border
so that is the latest we have from the
ukrainian president that the radioactive
chernobyl exclusion zone is trying to be
breached by
russian troops ukrainian forces battling
their um russian troops trying to seize
the chernobyl nuclear plant we
understand uh the ukraine president
saying this
is a declaration of war
against the whole of europe another
concerning development
today in this crisis